foreign
this morning on the dish and sauce
it's short friends the Idaho family
that creates incredible chorizo inspired by
The Basque region of Spain Dan and sadegi is
a James Beard nominee who's owned multiple
restaurants in Boise his latest was supposed
to start as a catering operation during
covid but it's become a sit-down dining
destination an authentic Taste of the old
country in the American West here we go
ever since the first Basque migrants cross
the Atlantic and arrived here in the late
1800s to work the Sheep trade the traditions
of food music and culture have been kept alive
at the center of that Community today is Dan and
sadegi his accordion and his authentic Cuisine
most especially is chorizo what do we do well
we started off here with our pork shoulder and
we've added some back fat we want to get
about that 65 percent lean to 35 percent
fat in violation of the age-old saying and
sadhi showed us exactly how the sausage is
made so the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to add our whole garlic paprika
a little bit of Aleppo pepper and salt as
that's going this is just white wine nice
so we're getting some moisture here and
then this is the chorizero pepper sauce
this is what makes a chorizo chorizo
for Spanish and best people smells good
we're halfway there then in came the stuffing
machine we're just kind of bringing this up and
we're going to just add it right in there you
want to make sure we don't have any air pockets
then what we're doing is we're basically
putting this entire mount on there
so now the next thing we're going to do is is
rather fun you're just going to go ahead and
rotate at a comfortable speed and it'll just
start coming out and we want a little bit of
resistance not much just a tiny bit how's my speed
it's just fine so here we go and we just measure
it like this and we just kind of pinch it here
and oh and turn it okay it gives us our length
then the next one we're going to do the same thing
and we're going to go the opposite way oh okay
and Sonic still makes his chorizo the same way his
grandma Epi did from a recipe passed down over the
generations she was in command in the kitchen she
started as a seamstress came over as a very young
lady married my grandfather and had to learn
how to cook really quick and sadegi eventually
traveled to Basque country to learn more and
has run three restaurants in Boise the latest is
called ansats my cooking came out of that desire
to eat well and to eat those have those flavors
that I remembered growing up how did Boise become
such a Bastion for Basque culture so there's a
little bit of the history is a little bit like the
Irish in the sense that poverty drove the Irish
and poverty drove Basque people to leave but why
Boise Boise happened to be the largest town in the
area had the most boarding houses so the most bass
people came here and so when they finished hurting
they often stayed in those towns where they were
getting used to and getting getting to know people
a Basque Festival of food and arts called high
Aldi is held every five years in Boise bringing
in 30 000 people from around the world and the
City Sites include a basque Museum and multiple
restaurants and shops in 2019 and sadegi was
named a cultural heritage fellow by the National
Endowment for the Arts and sots has grown from
its initial Vision as a catering operation pushed
Along by Dan's daughter Ellie what has this place
been like for you it's been super interesting just
because we started during covid so it was kind of
just like constant fear of if we would make it or
not it was my first like real profession because
before I've always worked at restaurants worked
at my aunt's restaurant but I was like the bus
or girl and so now I had to take on leadership
for the insertegies the family business
goes beyond making traditional Basque food
to making traditional Basque music
what is it about the accordion nobody
really knows if you're doing it right
right it's kind of uh um they're like
I think that's pretty good I don't know
that's it that's all we know when it was finally
time to eat the table was stuffed a charcuterie
board it's difficult to find much charcuterie in
The Basque Country charcuterie really we see that
in other parts of Europe especially Italy but I
love charcuterie however I don't like a lot of the
Italian spices so what I wanted to do was take
charcuterie but present it with Basque flavors
calamari that was plump and extra meaty a BLT and
egg sandwich and the chorizo this is the one that
we patterned we're on recipe number 19 right now
yeah because we were trying our very best to get
to Grandma eppies chorizo casing is a little bit
crispy and that comes partially from the time that
it hangs I mistakenly called it a sausage earlier
but it is it is a chorizo is a sausage okay so I
can say that sure also mixed Croquettes eggs in
purgatory paella with sausage clams mussels and
chicken a burnt Basque cheesecake and a sugary
caramelized croissants called Queen among
so it's oh wow correctly it's dense but
I've also never been trained so I kind
of just throw things in the oven and be like
I hope it worked pretty good I hope it works
why is it so important for you to keep bass
culture alive in Boise I don't know how often
I actually think about something like that food
makes me happy I get to try things and flavors and
just like okay that that's really going somewhere
and and so when we're doing things that make us
happy and and make other people happy I feel like
we're going the right direction and we want to
thank the insatis for sending us this wonderful
spread all the way from Idaho dig in please
ask meatballs and salsa Espanola clams and matsac
salt Cod and Spanish cured ham um chorizo plates
the chorizo I think was the spicy one I had that
was right the spicy one yeah it was really good
um and the charcuterie board which is House made
and what's really cool is there's a house made
charcuterie there with Squid Ink like the black
black yeah really cool and and these both are Cod
um one is cod and one is the mixed Cricket
I believe we'll keep eating good stuff